we are going to do an old classic of a
chemistry demonstration and it's called
the screamin jelly baby
also known as the growling gummy bear
and basically it's a reaction between
sugar potassium chlorate only yields
calmed oxide and water will show you the
basic one first way we've got a boiling
tube or a large test tube and inside
this we've got our potassium chlorate
what we need to do first of all is
melted and this is a process that just
involves a lot of heat and it fuses or
melts the potassium chloride so it goes
from being there was the white powder
that you see here to a liquid so let's
hand over to Neil potassium chlorate
kclo3 and what's happening is that Neil
is heating it a very very high
temperature and it's becoming KCl
potassium chloride and it's liberating
the oxygen and once that's all
completely melted we'll introduce the
sugar in the form of a jelly baby okay
we're ready
what on earth just happened there is
that not what was supposed to happen no
we shouldn't about that fizzing for a
start that's really disappointing
was that failure that was a failure yeah
I'm really gutted yeah in a way my mom
why is it still going as well oh wow
that's it
yeah
is that part of the reaction it's the
jelly baby what's left of it it's oh
gosh so young on if I just to it around
you can see it's hollow its kind of it's
very odd it's as if the jelly babies
been eaten from the inside out we do we
do expect carbon to be produced by the
chemical reaction but this is unexpected
but you do expect sometimes the the
reaction to be so violent that the jelly
baby gets ejected from the actual tube
well I've never seen is actually the the
hollowed-out shell of a jelly baby and
it's a jelly baby corpse is where it is
I think in the interests of scientific
endeavor we need to do this experiment
again with a different color journey
baby so we did red jelly baby that's my
favorite flavor but we'll do green this
time because I can't stand those
it's good isn't it it's almost white
light that was being produced there as
well so that's more of the reaction we
expected instantaneous really violent
very exothermic and now within seconds
it's all over
marvelous because I think at this point
we need to make a confession because
Neil and I have colluded to try and deep
Brady different colored jelly babies do
not in fact give different kind of
flames we've had a bit of a tinker with
the potassium chlorate and decided to
jazz up the reaction in the only way
that period in videos knows how to and
so we added metal salts to the potassium
chlorate red was obviously strontium
strontium nitrate and the Green was
barium nitrates and that's why the
different jelly babies gave the
different kind of flames the best
reactions are ones that you can scale up
so if we just take this cooler tube as a
comparison that's the kind of scale of
reaction that's done in schools and
other places that do demos and this is
the period of videos version we're going
to not quite barking dog scale but a
larger scale nonetheless and we should
be able to fit not one not two but four
jelly babies a chorus of jelly babies
into this one okay for this one we're
just going to be extra safe extra
cautious so again she put a blast screen
around it and then lower the fume hood
as well
Wow
that was spot on
we usually get requests and feedback
from viewers asking for the actual
chemical reactions that go on so to
begin with when we did the fusing where
Neal was blowtorching the tube that's
the potassium chlorate they're becoming
potassium chloride and liberating the
oxygen in the form of gas and then the
next thing that happened was the
oxidation of the sugar
so there's your sugar structure and then
it's reacting with the oxygen it's a
very exothermic reaction generates a lot
of heat and it gives you carbon dioxide
and water in the form of water vapor or
steam and then this the heat from the
reaction itself actually creates carbon
in the form of the SIRT and you can see
there in the tube a lot of carbons form
there and that's that the black of the
carbon Surt and you also get a lot of
water vapor coming off that in essence
therefore what you've got there is sugar
plus oxygen giving you carbon dioxide
and water